in the decades immediately before the
birth of modern science the exploration
of the new world and the flowering of
the alchemical imagination confronted
European man with a bee well during
complexification of nature and the
primary symbol used to understand this
bewildering variety of phenomena was the
labyrinth the palace the Acropolis
complex stretched through time and space
architectonic pregnant with mnemonic
possibility the palace the court became
the symbol at the center of the social
mandala of the European imagination and
never more so than here at Heidelberg
where Frederick and Elisabeth
literalized the mnemonic and alchemical
intentions of the age in a vast
sprawling complex of red sandstone cut
with secret passageways hidden doorways
and complexity found ordinarily only in
the depths of the human unconscious and
the alchemical imagination
in their way Frederick and Elizabeth
were acting out the dream of Camelot in
their way they were acting out the
alchemical dream of the rebirth of the
king and queen in their way they were
laying the groundwork for a new
dispensation of human thought freed from
the medieval assumptions of guilt and
the need for redemption a point of view
that made human beings co-creators in a
magical universe with a loving deity all
that passed away with the fall of the
winter king and queen